and what you're seeing now is inhumane
that's why they won't allow the press to
come in it's a horrible situation
and everyone that's seen it nobody's
seen worse nobody's seen anything like
it
it is what they're doing now is
outrageous
and they should finish the wall
former president trump hitting back
after president biden
blamed him for the current border crisis
biden says that he
makes no apologies for rolling back
trump immigration policies
he also denied that migrants are coming
to the united states because he's quote
a nice guy
senator ted cruz is leading a delegation
of republican senators there at the
border today
he posted this video to twitter early
this morning
the other side of the river we have been
listening to and seeing
cartel members human traffickers right
on the other side of the river
waving flashlights yelling and taunting
americans taunting the border patrol
let's bring in brandon judd president of
the national border patrol council he
will also join republican lawmakers
at the border today he joins us by phone
from donna texas where there is a
facility that's overwhelmed with
migrants right now um
brandon thanks for being here good to
talk to you again how's it going down
there with this delegation of
republicans and what are they seeing
well i'm glad that they got to see what
they did last night we were the ones
that took them out to the border we
took senator cruz and the rest of the
senators out to the border we showed
them
where the crossings are taking place we
showed them where the smugglers were
and sure enough the smugglers were so
audacious
that they actually came right down to
the bank of the river on the mexican
side
and they were shining spotlights at us
they were shining flashlights at us they
were taunting us they were making fun of
us they were telling us
that we couldn't do anything um to stop
their the crossings that were taking
place
um that these people were gonna come
regardless um you know so they got a
real world view
of what we deal with on a daily basis
and now
they're in the the actual processing
facility and i and i heard the clip of
president trump
saying that nobody's ever seen anything
like this i was here in 2014. i saw what
took place in 2014 in these process
facilities
i saw what happened in 2019 and i can
tell you personally
that what we are seeing right now is
horrendous it is absolutely
um inhumane the way these people are
being packed
in these facilities it's just like
sardines there is
no room to even see the floor um they
are packed in there so tight laying on
on the ground so so yeah i mean
everything that you're hearing
the reporting is coming out of here by
these uh these senators that actually
want to know what the truth
is it's it's all accurate and and and it
should really upset the american public
i hope it is anyway
how do you how do you know that you know
that the people who were taunting last
night what were they taunting
by by the way and you know how do you
know who is are just families who are
being brought across by actual smugglers
how can you tell
so when when we're dealing with the
individuals as as law enforcement agent
myself as somebody who's been doing this
for 23 years
you know when you're talking to the
actual smugglers the way that they taunt
you and they were bringing down the
family units as we were
as we were sitting there trying to shine
our spotlights our flashlights on
on them um again when they when they're
when they're telling us that and i can't
speak on air exactly what they were
saying because it was filled with uh
with curse words
but they were telling us where we could
go shove it um but these were the actual
smugglers it's very clear
um who they were these weren't the
family units family units don't talk to
us that way because they're trying to
just
give up because they know that they're
ultimately going to get released
right i want to play this from the news
conference yesterday
this is uh president biden talking about
migrant the migrant surge and saying
that it's just normal what we're seeing
watch us
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy
there is a significant increase the
number of people coming to the border
in the winter months of january february
march
that happens every year the reason
they're coming is
that it's the time they can travel with
the least likelihood of dying on the way
because of the heat in the desert
yeah the numbers tell a different story
total encounters at the border last
month february
were up 177 percent
year over year migrant encounters were
up by about the same
amount brandon um and one of the you
know
first of all answer that because he
didn't get any pushback no reporter said
you know excuse me i think only about 13
of the families are being sent back and
the numbers indeed are
are a lot higher no and that and that's
and and i'm glad that there are so many
people that are fact checking
even liberal media outlets are fact
checking him because of what he's saying
is so outrageous
but i'm so thankful that there are
organizations and i'm not trying to give
you kudos but like fox news that is
willing to get out there and tell the
american public
what the actual truth is because if we
don't know what the truth is we can't
fix the problem define the problem and
we can fix it but when you've got a
president that's getting up there and
say well i'm guess i'm a nice guy
it's encouraging people to violate our
laws we can't do that otherwise we we
are no better than the country
let me ask you one one more thing
before i let you go this one really
struck me yesterday
president biden said some families are
not going back because mexico is
refusing to take them back
some not all we're in negotiations with
mexico that's going to change
they should all be going back so that
that seems very odd to me because a he
said you know you should come
uh he told everyone you should come if
you're facing oppression in your country
he also has undone the remaining mexico
plan so
that statement seems very confusing to
me based on what he says his policy is
yeah completely and totally
contradictory that's political rhetoric
right there
if he wanted mexico to keep everybody
there he should have kept
the remaining mexico policy in place but
he didn't he's the one who invited
this problem that we're currently
dealing with
yeah got a big problem on their hands uh
brandon judd thank you very much for
being here good to see you today